[موسيقى]
في كتابه هتاف البجد يقول المفكر الاسلامي
علي الطنطاوي ان الانجليزي او الفرنسي لا
يتاخر عن شكرك ان وته المملحه على المائده
ولا يقصر في الاعتذار اليك ان داس على ر
خطا في الطريق وان راى كلبا مريضا تالم
عليه وحمله الى الطبيب وهو انيق نظيف مهدب
اللفظ لا يستهين بذره من هذه الاداب لكن
يتابع الطنطاوي هذا الانجليزي او الفرنسي
لا يجد مانعا يمنع رئيس وزرائه ان يامر
فيصب النار الحاميه على البلد الامن ليقتل
الشيوخ والنساء وال طفال ويدمر ويخرب
ويذبح الابرياء ويفعل ما لا تفعله الذئاب
ذوات الظفر والناب ثم يدعي بعد ذلك انه هو
المتمدن الى
العناوين نتنياهو يكذب تصريحا نسب لبايدن
حول حل
الدولتين منسق اوروبا اسرائيل مولت حماس
لاضعاف السلطه
اعلاف الدواب بدل القمح من اجل رغيف
لمقاومه
الجوع وزير الدفاع يقتحم مكتب نتنياهو
ويهدد بلواء
جولاني جنديه اسرائيليه حماس قطعت اعناق
50 مليون طفل
يهودي بعد جنوب افريقيا تشيلي والمكسيك
واندونيسيا تنوب عن العرب
20 الف طفل ولدوا في غزه منذ بدايه
العدوان تعرف على شبيه وائل الدحدوح في
الضفه
الغربيه مرحبا امريكا واسرائيل شراكه
الفيل والنمله من يحكم من من يشتغل عند
الاخر ومن القادر بينهما على فرض قراره
عند الاختلاف للكاتب التركي المعروف اتكو
ريحان راي معتبر نعرضه في ختام الحلقه لكن
ما الذي دعانا الان الى تجديد هذا السؤال
نتنياهو رئيس وزراء اسرائيل بنيامين
نتنياهو يضرب كلام الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بعرض حوائط البيت الابيض ويكذبه بكل
ثقه كما قيل ثقه غلبت ابن سهل الاندلسي
الذي قال لما راني في هواه متيما عرف
الحبيب مقامه فتدللا
نتنياهو عرف سر كيانه عند الغرب فتمرد قال
الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدن خلال اجابته على
سله الصحفيين انه تحدث مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو هاتفيا
لمناقشه الحل الممكن لاقامه دوله مستقله
للفلسطينيين مبينا ان نتنياهو لا يعارض حل
الدولتين مع وجود عدد من الانماط الممكنه
ويرى بايدن انه من الممكن تحقيق حل
الدولتين خلال ولايه نتنياهو لم يكد تصريح
بايدن يبرد حتى اطلق صاروخ عابر للقارات
من تل ابيب سخن معركه ذات الالسن فنفى
مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ما نقل على
لسان بايدن عن لسان نتنياهو مصير قطاع خزه
يخلق خلافا حادا بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده اهم حلفائها خاصه في حربها ضد
حماس بالنسبه لواشنطن الخيار الوحيد
للسلام الدائم في المنطقه هو اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه واعاده اعمار غزه لكن لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو راي
اخر يجب ان تكون لاسرائيل سيطره امنيه على
كامل الاراض الواقعه غرب نهر الاردن هذا
شرط ضروري يتناقض مع فكره السياده
الفلسطينيه اقول هذه الحقيقه لاصدقائنا
الامريكيين هذا ليس تعليقا جديدا لرئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو من الواضح اننا
نرى الامر بشكل مختلف نعتقد ان
الفلسطينيين لديهم الحق في العيش في دوله
مستقله تتمتع بالسلام والامن موجه من
الانتقادات لمواقف نتنياهو شهدتها
واشنطن لكن ماذا استفاد الفلسطينيون من
عاصفه الغضب هذه يستطيع بايدن بهدوء وبعد
جلسه يوجا اذا احب ان يقلد ايطاليا ويعلق
المساعدات العسكريه الطارئه لتل ابيب التي
تحرق بها الان غزه انتصارا لمكانه البيت
الابيض على الاقل فلا يليق ان يتهمه رئيس
حكومه هي اساسا عاله على الاقتصاد
الامريكي بفبركه الاخبار الكاذبه يعلق
مراقبون علما ان كثيرا من الامريكيين قد
سئب هذا الدلع غير المحدود من ت
35% americans the current level of a is
right 15% too much 14% it's too little
and 36% the largest single group here
they're unsure national war tax
resistance coordinating committee they
have advice they have lawers what we
doing now is more than 50 cents out of
every doll we give toed government go to
we for geno we got
حتى رئيس اسرائيل بلا زغره من حضراتكم
الذي يلعب تاريخيا دور المزهريه في تل
ابيب تحول الى صقر في زمن حكم الحريديم
الواف وقال لامريكا لا لحل الدولتين خلافا
لما تريده وتطالب به الولايات المتحده قال
الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرتسوغ ان
الاسرائيليين لم يعد بمقدورهم التفكير
الان في اي عمليه سلام مع الفلسطينيين كما
اضاف ان تلبيب فقدت الثقه في هذه العمليات
بعد الهجمات التي شنتها حركه حماس وفصائل
فلسطينيه اخرى في السابع من اكتوبر وزير
الامن القومي الملتهب تطرفا ايتمار بنفير
والذي اصبح بحسب محللين متحكما بسقف
الخطاب الحكومي
لخص المطلوب تهجير الفلسطينيين وانهاء
المقاومه بدوره قال وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار بن كفير ان الرؤيه لليوم
التالي للحرب في غزه يجب ان تكون باستمرار
السيطره على القطاع وتشجيع الهجره الطوعيه
وقتل يحيى السنوار واشار بن كفير الى ان
التسويه السياسيه لن تحقق الامن لاسرائيل
وسيتكرر ما جرى في السابع من اكتوبر الشيخ
بيرني ساندرز عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
وهو يهودي اشتراكي يناصر الشعب الفلسطيني
اكثر من بعض السياسيين العرب ساندرز ينذر
الولايات المتحده وقيمها لانها اصبحت
متواطئه في كابوس الشعب الفلسطيني وفي
كلمه له امام المجلس قال بيرني ساندرز انه
يجد صعوبه في فهم سبب عدم تحرك الكونغرس
لوقف معاناه الفلسطينيين ومعالجه الكارثه
الانسانيه التي يواجهونها في القطاع مؤكدا
ان الولايات المتحده متواطئه في الماساه
التي يعيشها ملايين الفلسطينيين في زمن
الذكاء الاصطناعي هل ما يزال مقبولا اطلاق
مثل هذه
التصريحات المنسق الاوروبي جوزيب بوريل
يقول ان اسرائيل مولت حركه حماس لاضعاف
السلطه الفلسطينيه وتطيير حل
الدولتين
lao
ne الامين العام لحركه نحال الاستيطانيه
اليهوديه المتدينه
دلاس لا تريد ترى اي فلسطيني في غزه وتحدد
لهم وجهات الرحيل واللجوء
تكشف عن توجه الغزيين في ازمات انسانيه
صعبه ترغم على الرحيل هذا وداني متدين
تقول اعلاميه امريكيه لم تستغرق وقتا
لتكتشف ان ما تفعله اسرائيل في غزه هو
اباده جماعيه من طرف واحد تستخدم فيها
اضافه الى ترسانه الصواريخ سلاح القتل
عطشا
وبالتجويد
في برد شديد وجوع يشكون انعدام الاحتياجات
الاساسيه وشح المساعدات
تصلهم الاغراض اللي جبناهم يا ابن عم بعنا
الطناجر وبعنا الكابون اللي بس تلمها
ببيعها بدهم مصروف لصغار من وين راح اجيب
لهم وفي تصريحات حديثه للمدير العام
لمنظمه الصحه الفلسطينيه قال ان اربعا من
خمس اسر في النصف الجنوبي من قطاع غزه
يقضون اياما وليالي دون طعام وان الاباء
والامهات يجوعون حتى يتمكن اطفالهم من
تناول الطعام مشهد من مجعات الحروب
العالميه
سكان غزه يطحنون اعلاف الحيوانات لصناعه
الخبز منها ونحن اخوانهم العرب ناكل الجبن
والجبن ياكلون طبعا ها المطحنه الوحيده
الموجوده في الشمال هي مطحنه قديمه اصلا
يعني عمرها ما يقارب 100 سنه فضره انتاجيه
ضئيله جدا مع وجود كميات قليله من القمح ل
اصلا هذا القمح يعني مخصص للطيور الواب
الله يعز الناس اضطرت تستخدمه المطحن طبعا
نشوف الدور يعني بالاسم شوف الدور قديش
بينتظر على الدور عده ايام عشان يطحن
القمح له اصلا للطيور او للدواب وبعد هيك
بستخدمو يعملوا
[موسيقى]
من
لم يجد جنود الاحتلال غير هذا الديناصور
البلاستيك للرد على فيديوهات القسام التي
تصور خدمه توصيل القذيفه الى الدبابه بكل
شجاعه بكل الاحوال يقال حسنا فعل جنود
اسرائيل باستخدام هذا الحيوان المنقرض
للتعبير عن جيشهم الذي قتلت نيرانه حتى
الان خمس قتلاه في غزه ذكرت وسائل اعلام
بريطانيه هذهه المره نقلا عن بيانات للجيش
الاسرائيلي ان النيران الصديقه تقتل نحو
واحد من كل خمسه قتلى من الجنود
الاسرائيليين في غزه وتشير بيانات الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان 17% من الجنود الاسرائيليين
يقتلون اما بنيران صديقه او خلال حوادث في
ساحه المعركه والده الجندي الاسرائيلي
القتيل في الاسر رون شيرمان تخرج عن صمتها
وتتهم جيش دولتها بالتضحيه بابنها وقتله
عمدا بدل اعادته حيا من غزه عد يوم الا
قبل يوم واحد من اخبارنا بانه مات قالوا
لنا انه على قيد الحياه بشكل شبه مؤكد
ولكن بعدها بيوم طرقوا بابنا وقالوا لنا
رون قتل على يد حماس وصلتنا رساله مفاجئه
من الطبيب
ين الجثه وعمل صو مقطعيه واخبرنا بعدم
وجود اي جروح ناجمه عن اطلاق نار او اي
كسور او دليل على تعرضه للضرب او علامات
لكدمات او اصابه خارجيه او صدمات عندما
يتعارك الاطفال يهدد بعضهم بعض باحضار
ابيه او اخيه الاكبر وزير دفاع الاحتلال
يقاف يكاد يقول لنتنياهو ق اوف وانت
بتكلمني ويهدد باحضار لواء جولاني بعد
خلاف اثناء محاولته اقتحام مكتب نتنياهو
وكاد ان تستعمل فيه الايدي عد عن الصراخ
والشتائم كشف موقع وال الاسرائيلي ان وزير
الدفاع واف جلنت حاول اقتحام مكتب رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو وكادت الاوضاع
تتدهور باتجاه شجار بالايدي وهدد جالنت
وزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه رون ديرم باحضار
لواء جولاني للسيطره على الوضع في مجلس
الحرب وبحسب موقع ولا فان الطاقم نتنياهو
رصد طاقم جالنت اثناء تسجيله لمجريات
الاجتماعات الامنيه على شريط صوتي ما فاقم
التوتر المشتعل بين الطرفين ما يثير جنون
اسرائيل هو فشلها في القضاء على حركه حماس
القادره على مواصله ضربها لعده اشهر قادمه
بشهاده امريكيه افادت صحيفه ول ستريت
جورنال ان تقديرات استخباريه امريكيه اكدت
ان حركه حماس لا تزال تمتلك ذخائر تكفي
لضرب اسرائيل عده اشهر ونقلت عن مسؤولين
اسرائيليين قولهم انه رغم الحمله الجويه
والبريه في غزه فان هدف تدمير حماس لم
يتحقق بعد حمزه صداح مؤثر فلسطيني نبيه في
وسائل التواصل استطاع جر جنديه اسرائيليه
الى اختراع ارقام تصاع
لا تصدق عن قتل اسرائيل في عمليه طوفان
الاقصى فقالت دون ان تنتبه للكوفيه
الفلسطينيه على كرسيه ان حماس قتلت 50
مليون طفل اسرائيلي تخيلوا 50 مليون يعني
اربعه اضعاف عدد اليهود في العالم وبدك من
نتنياهو ما يكذب على
بي
2000 hos
is something number
how near
half
isli
gazon
[موسيقى]
طفله امريكيه من اصل فلسطيني تتعرض لتهديد
مروع بذبحها وقطع راسها من قبل مدرس يهودي
رفع علم اسرائيل في قاعه التدريس في
الولايات المتحده وليس في اسرائيل فاعتبرت
الطالبه رفعه في الصف غير مناسب كما اكد
الشهود فضلا عن والديها علاء عفيفي ولينا
الشروف المدرس الدافن تم توقيفه ثم
الافراج عنه بكفاله
ماليه
that unfold of scho in central georgia
one month ago 51y old social studies
teacher benjamin rees was arrested for
allegedly threatening to behead their
daughter slit her thr told him found his
displ isra
fl ضيفان على قناه روسيا اليوم مصري ميد
بالطبع للشعب الفلسطيني واسرا متشدد اعتقد
الاخير انه
سيرعى
بمناصب عبيده فقال له فورا انا ابو عبيده
انا قريبه ما رايك في ذلك سيد ايلي نيسان
يقول لك بانه لو استمرت هذه الحرب 100 سنه
لن تتمكن من القضاء على حركه حماس بكل
بساطه ايه لاينظر انا لا اعرف ان دكتور
حامد هو مصري او هو الناطق بلسان بحركه
حماس فعلا عندما احد يسمع ما يقوله
الدكتور حامد كانه انا الاثنين انا انا
قريب ابو عبيده عارف ابو عبيده انا قريبه
ابو عبيده اللي كوي
ومدمر وعامل فيكم كل دكتور حامد ارجعلك
اعود لك لو سمحت فريد مثقف سلطه افتراضي
سيرافقنا في البرنامج يقول ان العرب لا
يقاضون اسرائيل بدماء
الفلسطينيين حتى لا يقا قال شهد شاهد من
اهله بعد جنوب افريقيا تشيلي والمكسيك
بموقف كثير شيك ومرتب مع غزه حيث انهما
احالت حرب اسرائيل على الفلسطينيين الى
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه التحرك القانوني
الجديد ياتي في وقت بدات فيه محكمه العدل
الدوليه النظر في الوثائق المقدمه من قبل
دوله جنوب افريقيا بشان جرائم الحرب
الاسرائيليه في قطاع ز رساله الاحاله
التشيليه المكسيكيه تدعو الجنائيه الدوليه
الى اصدار امر للكيان الاسرائيلي بوقف
عدوانه فورا على غزه البرلمان الاوروبي
تطور موقفه بشكل لافت فابتعد قليلا عن
الجلاد برفضه قتل المدنيين بالنار او
بالجوع في غزه لكنه طالب بتجريد الضحيه
شعب فلسطين من مقاومته وسلاحه الخفيف جدا
بالمقارنه مع مع المعتدين فداخل قبه
البرلمان الاوروبي يرفع نواب كثر اصواتهم
ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والحليف الامريكي
هنا ايضا صوت البرلمان باغلبيه
312 صوتا على مشروع قرار لوقف اطلاق النار
في غزه والاسراع في ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى القطاع لكن مع شرطين يدعوان
الى تفكيك حركه حماس والافراج عن الاسرى
الاسرائيليين يقول شيخ ازهري لو لم يكن
منع الظلم فرض عين على كل مسلم لقلنا ان
اندونيسيا قامت بفرض الكفايه عن الدول
الاسلاميه برفعها دعوا ضد اسرائيل في
محكمه العدل الدوليه افادت صحيفه معاريف
العبريه ان اندونيسيا قامت بتقديم دعوه
قضائيه جديده ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى
محكمه العدل الدوليه في لاهاي وفي تصريح
لموقع جاكارتا بوست الم محلي اكدت وزيره
الخارجيه ريتنو مرسودي ان هذه القضيه
ستعزز دعم النظام العالمي القائم على
القانون الدولي وستدعم حقوق الفلسطينيين
النائبه الفرنسيه دانييل اوبون قالت في
جلسه عامه لقد انقضت جنوب افريقيا شرفكم
جميعا تقصد شرف الدول الاوروبيه لنكون
واضحين les gns occident de de don des le
deti dro humains au reste monde preuve
de complaisance son gard quand il ne lui
apporte pas comme les etats-unis d' un
soutien militaire et financier c'est
l'afrique du sud la nation arc-en-ciel
qui a subi l'esclavage la colonisation
et l'art dont le peuple sa libert au ter
du trs longue et trs dur lutte de
libration nationale c'est ce pays
africain qui a sauv notre honneur tous
et toutes enfant la fois la cause du
peuple palestinien celle du droit
internation etum
enti احنا شعب بنحب الحياه رغم الموت
والقتل والدمار تعثر عقد قيران العروسين
مع اندلاع الحرب في غزه بعد هجوم السابع
من تشرين الاول اكتوبر الماضي واضطرا الى
تاجيل حلمهما والنزوح الى جنوب قطاع غزه
بما تيسر من امكانات تزينت العروس وارتدت
الثوب الفلسطيني التقليدي وبارك النازحون
فرحه العروسين على الرغم من الحرب والدمار
والموت في غزه تاكيدا على اراده الحياه كل
عشر دقائق يولد طفل جديد في غزه والامم
المتحده تحصي ولاده 20 الف طفل في القطاع
منذ بدايه العدوان فهل تتحرك الجمعيات
النسويه
لمناصرته ام انها ليست جهه اختصاص
اختصاصها فقط جدالات ميوهات
وحجابات الف طفل ولدوا في جحيم حرب غزه
منذ اندلاعها في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
بمعنى ان هناك طفلا يولد كل عشر دقائق
ايمان رجل فلسطيني بخالقه جعله يرتجي
الجنه باطعام قطط لا حول لها ولا قوه في
هذه الحرب الكونيه على غزه ايش بتعمل يا
حاج ايش بتعمل الله خلقهم هدول ما فيش اكل
ولا شرب لهم ربنا سبحانه وتعالى سخرنا لهم
عشان نطعمهم يعني كل يوم تجيب لهم اكل
والله الحمد لله كل يوم من الغالي غالي
غالي انت غالي وبعدين الحيوانات يمكن ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى يكرمنا فيهم هدول ويدخلنا
الجنه هون هون اطعم اله او الهره لو كانوا
عليكم حارون يعني بعدين النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم ما فوقها من النوم وهي نايمه
على العبايه تبعتهم كل يوم انت قاعد والله
الحمد لله كل يوم قاعدين هينا و فضل
ربنا ان شاء الله ربنا هيك يكرمنا بس وك
عين اما هذه الطفله النازحه فكان من
المحال عليها ان تنجو بنفسها وتترك قطتها
لغدت اسرائيل هذه بست حبيبتي بحبها اكثر
من روحي لما طلعت ما اخذ معي ولا شيء الا
غير بس لبسها يعني لو ماتت بعيد الشر ايش
بدي اسوي بزعل بصير اعيط بدي غيرها بدي
ابصر ايش خلص هي عقلبي البسها خلص هيسه
فيها روح زي البني ادم ما بقدر اسيبها مع
انه الاكل قليل بحسب حسابها زي اهل الدار
ما بقدر اسيبها خلص هذ زي زي اختي الجوع
ليس سببا كافيا
لقساوته الانسان السليمه حتى على الحيوان
طفل نازح في غزه يتقاسم ما بقي من طعام مع
قطته شايف ام بتبكي
ضنا علشان مات في الغر جعان اخيرا فاصل مع
وائل الدحدوح فرع الضفه الغربيه كما وصفه
اهل بلدته عناتا مع كل التحيه والمحبه
لشخصه الودود
ولوائحه يا اخوان وائل
الدحدوح فرعان يا الله
شو نفس الشكل سبحان الله وراسي من
ورا الله يعطيك الصحه يا
عدمي
ختاما تقول الشائعه المزمنه ان اسرائيل
تحكم الولايات المتحده من خلال نفوذ اللعب
اليهودي الامريكي لكن مفكرين كثر يقولون
العكس ومنهم الكاتب التركي اتكو ريحان
الذي يسخر من فكره ان امريكا تخدع وتقاد
من قبل اليهود المتطرفين بل يقول ان
اسرائيل تحتاج واشنطن لتبقى على قيد
الحياه
وان الولايات المتحده تحتاج اسرائيل لكي
تبقى في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الولايات
المتحده هي التي تقود اسرائيل التي تاسست
براي الكاتب لاسباب تتعلق بمصالح
الامبرياليه الغربيه وان وجودها قائم الان
لان الولايات المتحده تريد هذا الوجود الى
اللقاء خذ بد واشرد واكسر
واخرب ولا حد يقدر يقول لي عملت
ايه ما انا وحبيبي في عيني اثنين في
واحد فحنا
را كل
البجاحه
[موسيقى]
ه